welcome back
Our Guest fun fact once had Thanksgiving
dinner with
Barbra Streisand you guys
[Applause]
hi thank you for having me
hi guys
for you why are you standing
oh my goodness
hi I'm so excited I got to do Billy on
the Street like many years ago I did I'm
an oh dear you are
and you used to have that segment like
what would Drew Barrymore do oh yeah
would Drew Barrymore like that yes yes
and I just said random things and I told
you what you would like or not like by
the way it's true we did the segment but
that is so true to you you are someone
who probably hot I know you did had a
lot of voices about what you should and
shouldn't be yes and you were brave
enough bold enough to stand up and say
this is who I am thank you that's very
kind of you and you've carved out an
extraordinary career for yourself thank
you you have to be real strong and real
confident you know that's what Bros is
about really you know that's part of
what the movie is about what my
character has had to go through you know
he had to like shut out all those voices
and just forge ahead but they still get
to you you know you know what's
interesting though is that I didn't
write Bros by myself I wrote it with
Nick Stoller who's a straight man are
produced by Judd Apatow a straight man
they've made some of the funniest movies
of the past 20 years and also really
flag planting of owning the male
romantic comedy genre right exactly but
never about a gay man right so when we
started to collaborate on Bros five
years ago I was ready to fight you know
because I've had to fight for so long to
be authentic to be myself right luckily
for me those guys were very open you
know they wanted me to be me but so it's
weird sometimes like you're ready to
fight I've been so prepared to fight and
had to fight for so long but it's like
oh okay now I can I can relax a little
bit because these guys wanted me to be
true and be myself which is such a
blessing I'm very grateful for that yeah
that our entire studio audience are
fresh off of saying Frozen no way
what have you all started booing
it'd be a moment it'd be a daytime
moment well
um one of the core themes of this film
is storytelling
um for me I think it's the thing that I
maybe believe has the greatest chances
of bringing us together yeah that's what
I love about this movie it's not you
don't you know you don't sit down to
write a gay movie or a straight movie we
sat down to write a hilarious movie A
relatable movie that everyone in the
audience straight gay lgbtq can relate
to can see themselves and I hope you
experience that you know I think you
know and I'm not going to give away
anything at the ending but one of the
hardest things in any movie but
especially a romantic comedy is can you
stick the landing and boy do you stick
the lamp oh thank you thank you
thank you oh my God and it's such a
compliment coming from you because
you've made so many great wonderful
comedies and romantic comedies well I
mean you know who else is someone I wish
we could bring to our party who's that
someone who you know and actually hosted
a private screening of bros Mariah Carey
yes she did she did there we are
looking very sexy yes I I can't even
tell you how much I love her I love her
so much what was she like and how did
how was that evening she's the best uh
she's a big Billy on the Street fan and
she started she started tweeting about
it and stuff and so we connected that
way years ago she did a Billy on the
Street segment with me which was an
honor and then she ended up hosting one
of the first private screenings we had
for it and not only that this was
completely her idea she had a sequined
dress made with the Bros logo oh look at
it if you have a photo there we are oh
my that's the girls logo across Mariah
well do you mind if we take a picture
and send it to her and we must all right
ready one two three
all right well speaking of meeting
people I have to say that one of the
best meat cutes I've seen in rom-com
history is with your other half in the
film Luke McFarland wow I cannot handle
you have to have kind of love at first
sight this is no doubt I had love at
first sight and he is here may I please
bring out Luke McFarland
[Applause]
to fall in love the second we see you
and it works you do except for Luke is
it true that when you first met Billy
you thought he was angry or he had an
angry look on his face the first hold on
don't tell us we're gonna go to a quick
commercial break we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]